hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft ich werde heute
in der folge einfach mal so ein bisschen
denke diese häuser weiter bauen wo ich
schon die ganze zeit dabei war
oha da sind so komische oha was sind
hier passiert keine ahnung vielleicht
enger in die luft geflogen
ich werde einfach mal so ein bisschen an
den häusern hier weiter bauen sodass
verstimmen sind das verstimmen also
wissen sie was für ein tag ist dienstag
einer seite aber heute hat auch
konkreter seine hundertste hero projekt
folge
also ich sitze mit der tabea so also ich
stehe hier mit diesem liebenswerten man
seinen namen weiß ich es gerade nicht
wie geht es ihnen
und ja also erstens ziemlich süß und ich
werde mich fragen was ist heute für tag
als ich die branche und wir stellen dir
auch mal eine frage und zwar wissen sie
was heute für ein tag ist
was war das bin ich hier
was ist das alles
oha ich bin in der ich bin in der mega
projekt welt ich bin in der mega projekt
welt oha hier wohnt im beziehungsweise
wohnte war hier fehlte aber auch ganz
schön viel
ich bin ich denn hier her gekommen
da wohnte mojang minecraft
krass
die von terry ole
da war mal ein haus
meine pilz kuh ein tanklager ist auch
noch da darunter meint keller
auch hier war unser gemeinschaftshaus
was nie jemand so richtig wirklich
genutzt hat und hier war diese das wo
sich jeder was nehmen konnte von spark
damals krass fleisch bude kuchen palast
sind auch brunnen hier sollte man
bordell von rhi wie entstehen davon
selbst lp dieser hohe energie turm und
hier auch noch so ein paar sachen die
kenne ich alle noch gar nicht das ist ja
cool
ach und hier hat mal zornig gewohnt viel
rotwild pilz bei simons baum fehlt aber
ganz schön viel
hier noch mal ein schild da hab ich doch
mal drauf geschrieben alles gute zum
geburtstag
krass wie berichtet sie hergekommen ist
gomez haus sie auch ganz schön viel
verändert diese komischen säulen und so
was alles und hier um sein sein riesiger
keller
und hier die beatles festung mit dem
coolen durchgang hier unten
cool das ist alles noch hier
krass dass das damit so quasi alles
angefangen hat das echt krass
es ist echt heftig was hier alles
mittlerweile gebaut wurde
ich werde immer schneller wie ich jetzt
hier gelandet
dass ich jetzt beifahrer beim 1 1 schoss
die aktie von hier oder wie es anderen
bären
oh mein gott weil ich da schlecht habe
ich mich echt schon krass verbessert
mittlerweile ist muss man sagen ach das
war noch die diaschau mit den ach so ja
und jetzt sagt clampitt diamanten habe
schon gefunden
dort ist nicht die sache ernsthaft ach
ja stimmt wir haben 30 folgen dann keine
diamanten gefunden und er bekommt
einfach in als gast mitbürger hat direkt
welche gefunden
walter war das witzig harris das jetzt
figuren machen könnte und die dann
irgendwo absetzen könnten an kämpfern
gott wie ich da rede
und was habe ich noch so eine qualität
stimme gehabt das schon eineinhalb zwei
jahre her locker
nicht schon wieder
jetzt bin ich hier an minecraft also
keine ahnung was da jetzt war ich hab
voll grad irgendwie so einen
klitzekleinen flashback mitgemacht durch
die mega projekt welt durch durch ein
paar alte videos das sollte jetzt so ein
bisschen das 100 zufolge special seien
eigentlich mag es nicht wenn man so
specials macht ich wollte wenigstens was
ganz kleines machen damit jetzt hier
nicht leute seien ganz normale folge
kommt ich möchte mich bei euch bedanken
für 100 folgen ich weiß nicht warum ich
mich da brannten muss weil es einfach
nur dreistellig wird ist für mich eine
zahl wie jeder andere auch aber es ist
jemand auf dem server
trotzdem sage ich mal danke dass ihr
immer fleißig dabei war fleißig
zugeguckt hat fleißig kommentiert
bewertet und mir auch tipps geschrieben
habe dezember ist keiner
und ja das sollte einfach jetzt sowas
kleines nummer sein um euch zu zeigen
was das hier ist weiß ich immer noch
nicht da dachten vielleicht einige am
anfang so hohe das ist vielleicht teilte
specials er weiß auch nicht was das ist
hier ja ja gut es tut mir leid dass in
der mega projekt welt richtig viele
blöcke nicht geladen wurden das war halt
irgendwie so dass der download also dass
sich die welt noch hatte und die welt
war beim irgendwie mega alt und die
ganze mods und schon geupdatet ich hätte
jeden einzelnen mord updaten müssen dass
man ihm die 70 mods und das hätte jahre
gedauert und um da die passende version
heraus zu finden das wäre echt ein
bisschen kacke gewesen deswegen möchte
ich wollte einfach so zeigen aber ich
glaube an den sinn war da auf jeden fall
dass ihr gesehen habt was ich damit
sagen wollte und zwar einfach dass so
viel passiert ist mit derzeit das habe
ich auch noch mal gezeigt hatte ich dass
ich dann ein paar videos gefangen war
was hat nichts mit der zeit alles getan
hat am anfang meine erste video so
richtig schüchtern so piepsstimme dann
halt die talkshow mit denen unter
anderem und noch andere projekte auch
skype mit sonic beispielsweise oder big
pictures mit gomez zusammen dann wollte
ich jetzt gar nicht alles raus greifen
weil das ist jetzt schon viel zu viel
arbeit mit bearbeiten wenn die folge
voran heute noch kommen soll weiß es
schon 4 uhr und ja weil sie nicht also
das sollte also ein bisschen zeigen dass
das ganze hier sich immer weiter
entwickelt das es immer geiler wird
immer größer und das ist immer
verbessert wird und deswegen bin ich
echt bin ich liebe euch dank bei einer
rambo beste gesichts felsen hallo
und ja die ich möchte mich einfach für
euch bedanken dass ihr die ganze zeit
dabei fahrt auch mit mir geduld hat als
ich noch nicht erzählt die ganzen
rüstung hatte beispielsweise
mittlerweile habe ich alle drei okay
sind zwei sachen wieder kaputt gegangen
aber gute freunde
ich würde sagen ich hoffe euch reicht so
was als special bei 200 meter mehr
arbeitnehmer aber ich bin halt zurzeit
einfach im abi stress und alles mögliche
und ich habe einfach wenig zeit so was
alles zu machen deswegen habe ich das
habe ich jetzt wenigstens versucht und
ja sonst würde ich sagen es euch
trotzdem gefallen hat könnt ihr eine
bewertung da lassen
natürlich sagen noch mal danke an
krankhafter und raul die beiden kanäle
findet ihr auch in der beschreibung ganz
oben die das am anfang da geleitet haben
mit dem umfragen ich habe echt keine
zeit gefunden selbst nicht dazu findet
bei uns ist einfach tag und nacht am
regnen deswegen ist auch keine auf der
straße und in einem dörfchen diese
kartoffel straße
danke dass sie das so ungefragt haben
das war echt mega geil ich bedanke mich
bei euch weil ich cool und sonst würde
ich sagen euch noch einen schönen tag
auf weitere 100 folgen hero oder
zumindest 100 geile folgen hero und
sonst würde ich sagen ich geh jetzt
wieder dahin wo ich mich ausgeübt habe
und zwar das glaub ich hier und sonst
würde ich sagen freunde
ich weiß nicht kann sein dass ich
irgendwas vergessen aber der rest
erklärt sich eigentlich von selbst die
lichtfeld ist auch kacke weil die sonne
die ganze liste wieder hell da ist ja
dunkel richtig komisch also dass immer
wollten davor und auch keine ahnung